[Musica]
qualcuno di voi conosce il significato
di questo gesto
questo è il gesto che viene utilizzato
da noi sud durante un'immersione per
avvisare gli altri che ora di tornare
alla barca il motivo per cui dobbiamo
utilizzare un linguaggio dei segni è
abbastanza semplice l'uomo sott'acqua e
muto
eppure il mondo sottomarino è tutt'altro
che silenzioso questa sono io alla mia
prima immersione in liguria mi ricorda
che mi trovavo a 20 metri di profondità
quando improvvisamente senti un rumore
fortissimo che mi spaventò inizia allora
guardarmi attorno per cercare la fonte
del rumore ma non vi di nulla guarda in
su allora aspettandomi di vedere lascia
di una barca passata sopra di me ma la
superficie dell'acqua era liscia e senza
nessuna inter statura
realizzai quindi quello che gli
istruttori mi avevano detto in classe il
suono sott'acqua via già molto più
velocemente nella che nell'aria e quindi
probabilmente la barca che era passata
si trovava a centinaia di metri da me ma
io l'avevo sentita così vicina nel mio
viaggio di ritorno verso la costa inizia
a riflettere a come gli animali
percepivano lo stesso suono che mi aveva
spaventata si erano ormai abituati
avevano in qualche modo cambiato le loro
abitudini a causa di questo suono
arrivata a casa la mia ricerca prosegue
e mi imbattei na il termine
anthropogenic noise pollution che sembra
complesso ma in realtà è molto semplice
si tratta di tutti i suoni prodotti
dall'uomo che hanno in qualche modo un
influenza sull'ambiente e le specie che
lo abitano
questi sono due sono g un sono gramma è
un grafico che mostra l'intensità e la
frequenza di un suono nel tempo
in particolare sono gramma di sinistra è
quello di una balenottera comune che
nuota indisturbata quello di destra è il
solo gramma della stessa vale notte era
comune con il sottofondo il rumore del
traffico marittimo è impossibile non
vedere come quanto questo secondo suono
sovrasti quasi completamente il primo
le balene sono animali che comunicano si
spostano e si accoppiano grazie al suono
producente cosiddetti canti che tutti
noi conosciamo bene il traffico
marittimo quindi è una delle principali
cause dell'estinzione delle balene
insieme alla caccia ai cambiamenti
climatici
ma perché concentrarsi sulle balene
direte voi
l'estinzione delle balene non solo
provocherebbe la perdita di un animale
socievole maestoso e che purtroppo non
conosciamo ancora bene le balene sono
anche delle ottime alleate dell'uomo
nella lotta ai cambiamenti climatici
perché compiono un processo chiamato
wayne pump le balene sono gli unici
animali marini a produrre delle feci
liquide che quindi galleggiano in
superficie portando con sé tutti i
nutrienti in superficie si trova il
fitoplancton che si nutre del ferro
contenuto delle feci e riesce così a
prosperare a compiere la fotosintesi
clorofilliana consumare il co2 e
produrre ossigeno
se pensate anche solo alla stazza di una
balena non sarà difficile capire quanti
nutrienti polare a fitoplancton che da
solo è responsabile del 50 per cento
dell'ossigeno che abbiamo nell'atmosfera
una ricerca australiana afferma che in
un anno una balena consuma 15.000 kg di
co2 per darvi un'idea un albero all'anno
ne consuma 30 di chili
il valore ecologico quindi di una balena
è uguale a quello di 555 alberi
la ricerca del fondo monetario
internazionale
afferma che se il numero delle balene
passasse da quella attuale di un milione
3 a quello di 45 milioni
questo provocherebbe un fortissimo
impatto sulla produttività del
fitoplancton
se anche solo questa produttività
aumentasse dell'un per cento
equivarrebbe a l'improvvisa comparsa di
2 miliardi di alberi maturi e pronti a
produrre ossigeno
è incredibile mentre l'uomo cerca
soluzioni e complessi e spesso costosi
per risolvere i problemi dei cambiamenti
climatici la natura ne ha già una
semplice economica e collaudata da anni
le balene
questa è la mappa della parte nord
occidentale del mar mediterraneo è una
zona dove il traffico marittimo è molto
intenso e sono poche le aree che non
sono attraversate da delle rotte navali
proprio in questa parte del mediterraneo
ogni anno migliaia di esemplari di
balenottera comune migra dallo stretto
di sicilia alle coste della liguria
è inevitabile che questa migrazione non
sia influenzata in qualche modo dal
rumore del traffico marittimo che spesso
porta alle balene a collisioni o
spiaggiamenti
come designer ho provato a dare una
soluzione a questo problema
il risultato è un'autostrada silenziosa
che si vada ad innestare nei punti in
cui il tragitto delle balene si
sovrappone a quello delle rotte navali
garantendo così loro una migrazione
sicura e tranquilla
il corridoio silenzioso sottomarino è
formato da moduli ovvero dalle corde
sulle quali vengono impilati degli
elementi fonoassorbenti
i moduli poi affiancati l'uno all'altro
formano le pareti del corridoio
sottomarino che se da un lato non
permettono al suono delle navi di
passare dall'altro lasciano libere di
entrare e di uscire le balene e gli
altri animali marini
se una balena infatti dovesse andarci a
scontrare contro le pareti del corridoio
le corde semplicemente si piegherebbero
lasciandola passare senza recare alcun
danno
il concetto base infatti di questo
progetto è stato sin dall'inizio quello
di guidare l'animale nella migrazione
senza mai intrappolarlo
per non creare un ambiente artificiale e
quindi totalmente estranee l'animale è
stato necessario studiare alcuni
elementi che esistono già nel mondo
sottomarino
uno tra questi è l'alga in particolare
larga corallina che appunto si trova
sulla barriera corallina è stata presa
di ispirazione per la forma gli elementi
fonoassorbenti langa che invece è stata
studiata per il suo principio di
galleggiamento
le corde infatti sono ancorati al
fondale e arrivano fino alla superficie
dell'acqua per permettere loro di
scoprire questa lunghezza è stato
necessario intervallare dei piccoli
galleggianti proprio come avviene nelle
alghe kelp la parte più tecnica del
progetto è stato lo studio di un
materiale fonoassorbente in grado di
bloccare le frequenze emesse dalle navi
e lasciar passare quelle emesse dalle
balene in modo da permettere loro di
continuare a comunicare nonostante il
corridoio
la ricerca sui materiali fonoassorbenti
sott'acqua non è ancora avanzata inoltre
le frequenze da bloccare erano molto
basse
il che ha reso tutto ancora più
complicato
nonostante ciò è stato possibile
individuare un materiale si grazia dei
piatti in metallo inseriti in una
struttura viscoelastica riesce a
bloccare le basse frequenze sott'acqua
questo progetto quindi è il frutto di
una collaborazione tra tre materie
il design per la parte di progettazione
spaziale l'ingegneria per lo studio
dell'elemento fonoassorbente ed infine
la biologia per la ricerca sui movimenti
dell'animale questa idea è il primo
passo di un lungo percorso che inizia
nell'oggi e si proietta nel domani è un
esempio di speculativi design una
materia che ha lo scopo di cercare
questioni da discutere e di provare a
creare possibili narrazioni future per
aiutarci ad interrogarci sulle
implicazioni sul nostro presente
la ricerca infatti sui movimenti delle
balene non dà ancora risultati
attendibili
inoltre il materiale fonoassorbente
ancora bisogno di test e collaudi
nonostante ciò ho sentito il bisogno di
provare a dare una mia visione futura
per provare a limitare il problema
dell'estinzione delle balene
all'inizio di questo progetto la domanda
che mi sono posta è stata come designer
cosa posso fare per creare un futuro
migliore
comunque l'idea spero non solo di aver
dato il mio contributo ma anche di aver
dato a voi che state ascoltando la
consapevolezza che qualsiasi sia la
vostra professione o passione
potete tutti dare il vostro contributo e
aggiungere un piccolo e originale pezzo
al grande puzzle multidisciplinare per
creare un futuro migliore e
possibilmente pieno di balene grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]